تحدثت مايا بلاكستون، منتجة قناة CNN 10،
مع شقيقين من غزة، محمد البالغ من العمر 11 عامًا
وشقيقته الكبرى أفا منذ أكثر
من أسبوع، حيث غادرت عائلتهم
منزلهم في مدينة غزة للبقاء في ما كانوا
يأملون أن يكون مكانًا أكثر أمانًا
بموجب عقوبات الأمم المتحدة.  الفندق الذي كان
قريبًا نقلونا جميعًا إلى
الطوابق السفلية من المبنى أه نحن
نتحدث عن 330 350 شخصًا في نفس
المكان الفندق نفسه النوافذ
تحطمت وسقط السقف في
الأيام القليلة الماضية من الإقامة في الفندق  لقد
نفدت مياه الشرب والطعام
في 13 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول، وأسقطت إسرائيل
منشورات في غزة تحث المواطنين على
إخلاء الجنوب، ولكن كان ذلك صعبًا
في الواقع، فقد استغرق الأمر من الأشقاء
وعائلاتهم 3 ساعات للسفر لمسافة 15 ميلًا فقط
إلى مكان إقامتهم.  مكان الأجداد في
مدينة هان
يونس، هناك الكثير من الأشياء التي تحدث
مثل التفجيرات، إنها عالية جدًا
ومخيفة حقًا، كما
انقطعت المياه وانقطعت الكهرباء،
وهذا أيضًا أمر سيء جدًا قبل
الحرب كان محمد  في المدرسة الابتدائية، الصف
السابع، كان متحمسًا للانضمام إلى
نادي الروبوتات، كنت متحمسًا جدًا
لأنه كان لدي الكثير من الأشياء الممتعة التي
كانت ستحدث ولكن بعد ذلك
بدأت الحرب ولم يعد بإمكاني الذهاب إلى
المدرسة بعد الآن.  اضطرت العجوز إلى
إلغاء حفل خطوبتها الأسبوع الماضي، فقد
فصلتها الحرب الآن عن
خطيبها الذي يقيم مع
عائلته، كما تعلمون، إيصالات
الخطبة M تدق الثقب في
الفستان، لذلك كان ذلك
مدمرًا للغاية  ما زلت لا أفهم
خطيبي حقًا، تحدثت قناة CNN 10 أيضًا
مع تاليا البالغة من العمر 12 عامًا والتي تعيش في
هولندا، وهي مدينة في إسرائيل تقع على بعد
أميال قليلة إلى الجنوب من تل أبيب،
لدى تاليا ثلاثة أشقاء أكبر منها سنًا  هو
مهندس قتالي في الجيش في الواقع
كان في المنزل يحتفل
بالعيد اليهودي سيم توراة عندما بدأت الحرب
بدلاً من الاحتفال معه
بإجازتنا ويومنا المقدس وهو أحد أقدس
الأيام في العام الذي تم استدعاؤه إلى
قاعدته كان لديه 15 عامًا  دقائق للاستعداد كنت
أبكي وكانت أمي تبكي لم أستطع
النوم بالكاد أكلت الجميع حتى لو كان
لا يعرف شخصًا ميتًا أو
مخطوفًا يعرف شخصًا يعرف
شخصًا ميتًا أو مختطفًا،
إنه شعور مخيف لدى الجميع
قلق للغاية هنا، لا يمكنك حقًا أن تشعر بالسعادة
كل يوم عندما تعيش في إسرائيل، يجب
أن تكون خائفًا مدى الحياة. تاليا أفا
محمد، جميعهم يعانون من
الصدمة. نحن الفلسطينيون لا نريد أي
سفك للدماء، نحن الفلسطينيون لا نريد
أي حرب، نحن الفلسطينيون لا نريد  أريد أي
خسائر في الأرواح من كلا الجانبين، آمل أن
تنتهي هذه الحرب وآمل أيضًا أنه ربما
يمكننا الذهاب إلى مكان أكثر أمانًا، نحن مجرد
أطفال لا يمكننا القتال ولا يمكننا فعل أي شيء،
هذا ليس خطأ أو خطأ أي
مواطنين أبرياء أيضًا  من جانبنا أو من
جانبهم